officer going down requesting everyone
give him in the person alone time in
this week's breakdown
[Applause]
welcome to Edmonton Alberta Canada the
great white-trash north home of prime
minister josh groban these two conical
heads got caught using a stolen credit
card doesn't everything already free up
they're not sure how Canada works makes
a ride-or-die chick to mount a Mountie
so her boyfriend can make a run for it
now he's violating the stores no shirt
policy dead end
I keeping that door locked is a fire
hazard he could sue there you go
try to bribe the cop with sunflower
seeds is my work there very addicting I
can't hear what he's saying but he's a
Canadian officer so I assume he's
apologizing
well the Taser only made him stronger
I'm starting to understand why American
cops just shoot to kill
alright let's check back in on the tits
of the operation Hey
bathrooms are for paying customers only
women can't go anywhere without stopping
to pee any chance you could hold your
driver's license up the camera you idiot
we may have a skank infestation in the
Attic her xscape plans fell through but
she wishes she landed on a softer aisle
guess back up takes a little longer when
your squad car is a moose they got the
maximum sentence six months in Winnipeg
that's a local burn I'm kidding it's
just a two minute minor and for that we
thank you